what's going on guys this is rob we are
back with dc's dark crisis and another
episode of infinite frontier which is a
really really cool uh is it really an
episode do we really call it an episode
in any event uh this video is sponsored
by display so let's talk about them real
quick and then we'll jump back into the
video
okay so the folks over at this plate
sent me five plates and you see four
here don't worry i know how to count uh
the fifth one is actually over here it's
the joker one that i already have set up
and i'll show you guys how to install
these here in a second uh this is my
whole gym setup by the way boost mode so
here's the thing uh they sent me uh five
of these right so there's a joker of
course there's batman superman i'm sorry
wonder woman superman and the green
lantern so the deal behind this is you
get 25 off of one and then you get 29
off of three or more uh but they also
wanted to show you guys how to install
these things so um they install by way
of magnets but they have these little
leaves
right here these little leaf protective
leaf things right here so give me one
second and i'll show you how this thing
attach it okay so this leaf right here
right this thing like literally it has
this little uh white cover
on the back of it right but you just
peel that off it's pretty simple um and
then you essentially press this against
the wall the way you would if you were
normally sticking something to it right
minimizing bubbles
little things like that um
you'd probably take more time installing
yours than i'm i'm doing here but uh it
comes out pretty solid the the
the thing that i'm contending with here
is i've got a textured wall as you can
see um so you won't really see it as
flat as it would be against a
non-textured wall but still okay so now
we got these magnets up um on the back
of the magnets that actually let me show
you another
set of magnets so on the back of these
magnets you have these little blue
things right here literally that just
peels off um and then you simply just
press it up against
you know this little square where it
says like place magnet here um i mean it
does tell you right there right to like
you know press hard you know for at
least five seconds honestly i had to
press a little longer than that because
it's a textured wall and kind of had to
push it around a bit but it serves this
purpose and then you basically just grab
your poster or your yeah your metal
poster metal display and then just
attach it right and it literally just
heats right there it doesn't really you
just magnetizes it to the wall which is
cool i need to fill this out
a little bit more but yeah that's how
this whole thing works so uh make sure
you guys check the link in the
description to get your your display
number is 25 off of one and then 29 off
of two but uh yeah let's get back into
our video
and so what this does of course picking
up after the last video that we did now
we basically end up joining captain
carrot oh my god i love captain carrot
people always ask like why do i love
captain carrot so much because he's a
super bunny so having said that
there's a bit of a conversation that
happens here between captain carrot and
machine head now one of the things about
machine head is we're not really given
any indication of who this guy is and in
fact even though captain carrick walks
in on him with his helmet off we never
actually see his face instead his helmet
is put back on and the two of them kind
of continue this sort of general
conversation but there's not a whole lot
doing here right and in fact i'm not 100
sure why this conversation happens in
the first place
but one of the big things that machine
head talks about is this idea of the
events that led to thomas wayne being
brought to them and it's just kind of
some theories and speculations we never
actually find out what they are instead
what we end up doing is shifting over to
thomas wayne and calvin ellis as they
are in the white house remember uh
calvin ellis is the the president of his
world and he's also superman at the same
time so he kind of balances these two
lives amongst each other doing the best
he can right while he had taken off to
do his thing he was gone for like 24
hours they'd kept the country running
but the reality is as president he kind
of has to be there right if the
president just disappears for 24 hours
panic is gonna set in because most every
major decision in relation to like being
commander-in-chief different things like
that bills that need to be vetoed or
approved have to go through the
president a person can't just take his
place unless he signs like literally was
it the 25th amendment or whatever it was
the one that that determines that he's
unfit to be president of the united
states but that's not something you just
randomly do you don't sign the line of
succession because you're going to be
going on a break
right not really the way things work
here so trying to kind of maintain this
balance is really intriguing now of
course what's funny is that thomas wayne
picks up on this idea that calvin never
really talks about his family too much
he never really has a discussion about
them and in fact one of the things that
he's also done is he's basically turned
the oval office into a kind of fortress
of solitude away from the fortress kind
of like a little mini fortress for
himself but allows him to basically
operate as both superman and president
at the same time now one of the things
he does talk about is the lex luthor
that's native to his universe about how
lex luthor's always kind of proved
himself to be this just you know
extremely dangerous enemy now if
anything this is probably williamson in
them establishing for us that there are
individuals who exist across the
multiverse that are basically
multiversal constants that they are for
the most part usually exceedingly
intelligent and dangerous even if
they're not always bad guys lex luthor
more often than not is a villain who is
dangerous however someone like alexander
luther from earth 3 is actually a good
guy but that's only because of the
nature of that universe that people who
are traditionally superheroes are
actually villains and people who are
traditionally villains are actually
superheroes so it's just the backwards
nature of that reality but barring that
particular universe itself in most all
universes lex luthor's a bad guy and
he's incredibly dangerous and that's one
of the things that calvin hits on is
because in this reality one of the
things that lex luthor had always tried
to do was achieve a means of
trans-dimensional travel right to leave
his reality and travel to other
realities in the multiverse he never
finished it but it was something he was
working on the fact that the the ship
that he had touched had resonated with
the vibrational frequency of this
universe points to the idea that lex
luthor even if he wasn't necessarily the
person responsible for it had some kind
of a hand in developing it and so that's
when they end up transitioning to lex
luthor's base of operations ultimately
breaking in and then once they get to
where lux luther's at they find he's
actually dead somebody's punched a hole
in his chest and that's what's so crazy
is because what it looks like is lex
luthor where they had presumably helped
lex luthor achieve this and then left
right they took the technology and
bailed out killing lex luthor in the
process we don't definitively know
that's the case but that's what it looks
like but again it's a mystery that leads
to yet another mystery if lex luthor was
killed in an effort to essentially use
his ability to travel across universes
then why and who who was it that did it
i mean obviously it's for transitioning
across universes but what's the greater
goal here what's the greater scheme now
once we get to the conclusion of this
all of this will make sense because
there is one gigantic guiding hand
behind all of this and it's amazing when
you get to the reveal because there's
who you've heard it is then there's who
it actually is but beyond that we end up
switching back of course to earth zero
into cameron chase now the big question
that a lot of you guys asked is how did
cameron chase survive the death or the
the explosion of captain adam this is
really williamson them kind of pulling a
macguffin right like extract leapt in
saved her and teleported her away i'm
not really sure why that was necessary
maybe it was to provide just some kind
of shock value for the comic or
something like that the fact that
extract saved cameron chase in and of
itself that's not really important it
doesn't really matter it's just kind of
like okay i mean i guess cool whatever
but i'm kind of curious to see what the
bigger picture is uh in terms of like
this grand scheme the thing about this
though is what they end up doing is of
course speaking with alan scott and an
obsidian and when they start asking
questions like what's going on here you
know why is all this happening you know
what where have you taken jade all that
kind of stuff the only response they're
given is from extract who says like
she's lost right kind of that she
resisted us and basically paid the paid
the price so presumably they left her
for dead out there now of course we know
she's not dead she's very much alive but
as far as alan's gotten them go they
don't really know what's going on the
bigger thing behind this though is that
when it comes to bones and all those
guys uh you know hector hammond and all
them they are kind of working as a joint
unit and they're all supposed to be
meeting at a particular location that
that really hammond ship should be
arriving there but one of the funny
things about this is that cameron chase
does not have all the pieces of this
puzzle and that's when she starts asking
questions like okay you need to tell me
what's going on here right like you need
to tell me what in the world is
happening like roy harper's supposedly
dead but you're telling me that they
came into contact with roy harper that
hammond has ray harper in his possession
the last we heard from him like what's
going on here right like you're telling
me all these people who had basically
died or coming back you're telling me
now we've got some big charter that
deals with the multiverse and what bones
does is offer a bit of an explanation
but even the explanation he gives is
still cloak and dagger right he says our
world is constantly under attack
oftentimes it's from people who are from
here from this universe right the joker
attacks gotham city and floods the place
with toxin or or something along those
lines right he says but the most
dangerous individuals who have attacked
our world have actually been from
outside right and this is one of the
cool things because one of the things to
remember here because the events of
really doomsday clock the actions of dr
manhattan that what we got was a
restoration of the entire multiverse
with all these crises right the way that
it originally played out is you had
crisis on infinite earth right that
reset the multiverse wiped out
everything before it and almost nobody
remembered anything about how how the
you know multiverse had been or that it
even existed before the events of crisis
on infinite earth right post-crisis you
got new earth a singular universe where
everybody got new origins and all that
kind of stuff that runs all the way up
to zero hour where you basically have uh
hal jordan when he becomes parallax
messing with the time stream momentarily
blinking it out of existence bringing
him back but it was an opportunity dc
used to rework people's origins yet
again then you go into infinite crisis
right that brings the multiverse back
you go into final crisis that makes the
heroes aware of the multiverse then you
go into new 52 the result of flashpoint
but the big difference is that with the
new 52 and the flashpoint event what we
ended up learning during doomsday clock
is dr manhattan had basically prevented
alan scott from ever becoming the green
lantern and in doing so the jsa never
formed that among a few other things led
to like huge gaps in people's memories
being removed the whole purpose behind
doomsday clock was to basically say you
know the original crisis on infinite
earth that zero hour that infinite
crisis final crisis flashpoint they all
happen and they're all part of one large
great big huge continuity everybody
remembers everything now and so when you
see these characters being depicted here
the anti-monitor the way he originally
appeared perpetua dr manhattan uh hal
jordan is parallax all these characters
they are all part of a continuous
singular timeline right and that's why
he remembers all of this is because all
their memories were restored of all the
crisis events that have ever happened as
opposed to people only remembering you
know little bits and pieces of the
history of everything that had ever
happened in the universe itself but it's
why you see him referencing heroes that
you would assume he wouldn't know
anything about right he wouldn't know
anything about the original anti-monitor
he wouldn't know anything about like how
jordan is parallax or something like
that maybe like mr mine during final
crisis he wouldn't really know about all
that stuff but now he does at the end of
the day he says we can't take another
time space event and the heroes are
doing nothing to cut it off at the past
he says so i bit the bullet and i made a
deal we'll be safe and the response of
cameron chase is safe from what and he
says you saw what captain adam did right
you saw what could happen if someone
from an alternate universe comes here
and attacks our world they would blend
in with the superheroes and by the time
the superheroes realized something was
wrong it would be too late and so at
that point she asked the question did
you know that that captain adam was not
from our world did you know that and you
sent me there anyway and his response is
i simply needed you to understand i
needed you to confront that captain adam
i needed you to know he wasn't from our
world i needed him to detonate possibly
kill you in the process and extract was
always going to save you but in the end
he's like we have to get out of here we
have we have a lot of work to do you do
not want to be on this ship when it
takes off and cameron chase shoots him
in the leg and says we're going like we
are all going to this location and
that's when he says you don't understand
the place that we're going to it's a
place of endings you've doomed all of us
cameron chase like we're all going to
die and so at that point of course
that's when we start to realize it's
basically going to earth omega and
that's the significance of this is that
earth omega basically appears to be a
place where everything ends right where
everything goes to die and so what we
end up doing is jumping back to roy
harper alongside jade and adam smasher
and all those guys power girl and
whatnot and a fight breaks out between
the two of them but it's more of a
misunderstanding that when they see roy
harper as basically a black lantern
because of the fact that they've been
through the multiverse and there's all
kinds of universes out there they
presume that hector hammond has
basically gotten his hands on a black
lantern and a black lantern has joined
the cause of hector hammond when that's
not the case instead it's basically him
just being possessed by a lantern ring
and of course he crawls out to jade for
help now jade of course responds and is
able to basically talk him down and
realize it is roy harper who somehow
returned from the debt and so that's
when they're kind of asking the question
okay what do we do here right what do we
do with all of this stuff and so that's
when you end up finding out that what
had gone on is that in the initial
conflict when you had jade who had gone
missing in the jsa building that
basically extract had shown up there to
attack all of them and when uh when the
whole gravy huge conflict had popped off
that a shot was made against jade which
had hit her ring and when that had
happened it had teleported her away
arrest you know along with what seemed
to be the rest of the jsa hence why you
have power girl here and so on and so
forth and they've basically been
traveling around trying to defeat these
guys where and when whenever they can so
that's what led them to this particular
conflict here the bigger issue though is
that because of the fact that they
overhear a broadcast where hector
hammond is supposed to be meeting with
bones and cameron chase and extract and
all of them at a particular location
they say well if they're expecting
hector hammond we can't disappoint
otherwise they'll know there's something
going on with their plan so they
ultimately teleport to that location as
well only for us to find out it is
indeed earth omega the kicker is that
when they get here they end up finding
out that some of the occupants here are
the shadow demons of the anti-monitor
right from like the original crisis on
infinity event and so again you kind of
get this back and forth bit of a thing
here where you've got barry allen who's
just running super fast on this device
and he's being manipulated by
psychopirate you got jade and you got
the jsa who were like we can't do this
on our own right if those are just the
shadow demons of of anti-monitor and
that's just them that's more than we can
handle just based on sheer number alone
let alone the power they possess so like
we need to call in like the justice
league the rest of the jsa the titans
the whole nine yards and they also
really decide that it's in their best
interest to leave but at that point roy
harper freaks out and says no like what
if my daughter's down there right so
like literally because everything's
popping off there their ship ends up
crashing into the ship of hector hammond
along with cameron chase and everybody
you just got this giant mayday that's
going on right even blasting into the
house of heroes that there's some kind
of a calamity that's going on and so you
have all the alarms that are basically
silenced by harbinger when you have
thomas wayne and you have uh superman
right calvin ellis who show back up here
that their question is okay like we have
to figure like like what in the world is
going on like who wants to stole the
ship of lex luthor or his technology
perfected it or whatever something's
happening with all these forces
basically coming together really
villainous forces uniting together
across the multiverse what's happening
here right who's bringing these guys
together what's taking place literally
they're like their enemies are
marshaling against them and they're
basically fumbling around in the dark
you have machine head who makes this
statement and says okay has anybody seen
or heard anything from the flashberry
allen why does anybody know where barry
allen is we sent him into the multiverse
he's supposed to be finding the the
source of all of this stuff or at least
something that we can use to figure out
what's going on here and the responsive
machine head is like he's nowhere to be
seen right he says but i nearly have the
shuttle rebuilt with the specs that you
sent over from lex luthor's lab i'll be
finished in no time we should have a
good idea of what he was up to and he
says use it to find out where it was
from and where it was going now one of
the other kind of funny bits of
discussion here is that you have calvin
ellis talking to batman or talking to
thomas and saying this all started with
you why and where thomas is like i don't
know man i'm a nobody the response of
calvin is no no you're a remnant of a
broken reality right but more than that
you are the father of a great hero you
know maybe we've been looking at all the
wrong places and should look more at you
right maybe you're you're the source of
this in some capacity and so what you
end up having is uh is basically a kind
of observation screen that thomas wayne
approaches and simply says like look up
batman right like show me batman and he
ends up seeing all these different
versions of bruce from across the
multiverse right batman beyond you get
batman from like the the red sun
universe there's all these different
versions of bruce and that's when he
comes to the realization that in every
single universe bruce wayne is always
batman in some capacity it's his destiny
it's always who he's supposed to become
and that's when thomas comes to the
realization that during tom king's run
trying to talk batman or trying to talk
bruce out of being batman was the wrong
decision that's not what he was supposed
to do that instead he was supposed to
help his son become a better batman
right that's just the nature of bruce is
to always become batman beyond that what
you have is calvin ellis who starts
talking to harbinger right the the
sentient computer here and says like
show me any and all signs of multiversal
travel since the multiverse was restored
at the very least it'll show us
everybody who's moving across the
multiverse but he's denied that and when
the question is why like it's one that's
not supposed to happen that any and all
information available to the multiverse
should be accessible by calvin ellis
even if nobody else because he's
effectively the leader of justice
incarnate of the multiversal superhero
team right the multiversal justice
league and that's when he's told you're
not allowed access to that information
and so what ends up happening is he and
calyx basically hack harbinger and when
they when they do they basically access
a message that is coming from barry
allen where he says like he's like this
is barry allen the flash from earth zero
reporting in and he says justice
incarnate call an emergency meeting now
right connect with the justice league
tell them that death follows us yet
again and that's when it's one of those
things where he's told that barry allen
had basically traveled to earth omega
and the response of calvin ellis is if
barry's gone to earth omega we have to
go as well we have to call ursuros
justice league we have to unite the
superheroes and we have to go to earth
omega because whatever it is that's
there is of such significance and a
significant incredible threat that it
challenges the existence of everything
it really is like this is a do or die
right this is an all hell kind of a
situation right like this will basically
bring the end of everything that we hold
dear and so before they're able to to
mobilize or even get on the move at all
they're all attacked by machine head and
so as soon as that takes place machine
head literally locks them all away like
just shuts the door puts them in what's
basically a kind of prison and then when
the question by by captain carrot is
asked we need to ask like why are you
doing this the response to machine head
is years ago my world earth 8 was
invaded by an alternate reality we tried
to fight the war in secret but
ultimately we lost and i lost for years
i questioned how and all the signs
pointed to one place earth zero and he
says now i don't want to destroy the
multiverse i just want to keep us
separate no more crossovers between
worlds but ironically i was not alone
there are a lot of people in the
multiverse who feel the exact same way
and so we came together knowing there
must be sacrifice to correct a great
injustice and so that's when you end up
getting the the reformation of the
injustice society and this is the
multiversal version of the team so
you've got superwoman from earth 3
you've got yellow lantern joker which is
amazing magog just some pretty heavy
hitters but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace